parents
I get more emails appearance from
parents talking to me about their kids
and ever more messages more reaching out
more than ever so said something the
middle of my project and that as well
addressing parents
please let them win on their terms not
yours no children
the children I'm not a direct indication
of who you are there are five product
there's proxies there's things but so
many of you are deploying your
insecurities about yourself on your
children because you genuinely care
about what people around you are saying
about them other families other friends
other relatives talking about your kids
you value more to them you value their
Pio Dee's excuse me
more than listening to your own children
and when I say listening you have to be
able to decode me zero to thirty year
the second year over twenty year old
it's not necessarily the words when you
actually get into an emotional or real
conversation it's their actions it is
your job as a leader of a business of a
family to reverse engineer the players
in the game and put them in the best
position to succeed than the thought
that so many of you
and the thought that so many of you at
parenting your children predicated for
short-term fulfillment to other people's
opinions devastates the [ __ ] and one day
was the estate - it probably devastates
me right now
and so that line he directly the [ __ ]
heart or your brain or your
consciousness please do something
I may never make a video more Pro to me
the mist like the byproduct of most
incredible Karen see the
disproportionate communitisation succeed
because they'll be confident who they
were and did not allow their people to
touch them and allow me to live in
happiness and be who I was and I read a
hundred messages a day from parents them
know they're not so sweet spirits please
understand that your concern of being
judged
by artificial treats its positioning
your children
not to fulfill the happiness that you
have to work for them your inability to
understand how the landscape changes
over the next 30 40 years is over
protecting their children from the
victories that they deserve it also
creates an unbelievable weakness for
them not to be able to deal I'm able to
deal it is my mother and father put me
into a framework that allowed me to fail
it allowed me to be me I've learned and
learned every day my shortcomings and
other people's opinions really easy way
to not be bullied is to not hear them in
the first place
cease to let your insecurities be
imposed and please don't hide them under
the false statements that you're trying
to do what's right for them what's right
for them is to give them freedom to be
themselves as long it is noble and fair
do not judge their creativity for the
angles they see that you do not see now
because history has proven it's
practical to understand you can't see
how they can please
please